eileen goo is 18 years old she's a skier
she was born in san francisco she's a
favorite to win several gold medals in
the winter olympics in china this year
but she's not going to be competing for
the country of her birth or her
citizenship
instead she's going to be on china's
olympic team she has one parent who was
born in china
and she switched sides despite the fact
she's american what does this tell us
about the moment we're living in and
about our future
will kane is the co-host of fox and
friends weekend he's also the host of
the will kane podcast which is excellent
he joins us now well thanks for coming
on this seemed like a significant story
do you think that it is
i think it is i think it's a significant
story if we consider that's about
something much bigger than eileen goo
right first eileen goo i mean it is it
is incredibly i think the only word we
can arrive at is ungrateful for her to
betray turn her back on the country that
not just raised her but but turned her
into a world-class skier with the
training and facilities that only the
united states of america can provide for
her to then turn her back on that in
exchange for money is shameful it's
ungrateful like a child that says i'm
out of here i'm moving somewhere else
after being raised in a warm home that's
what she is and she will soon i suspect
tucker come to regret it i mean take a
look at the chinese tennis player who
dared to speak out about sexual
harassment and then mysteriously
disappeared eileen goo i think has had
to sacrifice her american passport so
welcome to china i hope stardom and the
the riches that you have earned through
betraying america are all worth it
because you have definitely sold out
well that's exactly it and look at you
know this this girl's 18 you know you
make dumb decisions you get stupid
tattoos you renounce your citizenship to
go to china whatever you know young
people do dumb things but there should
be collective revulsion as we watch this
like we shouldn't make it easy for
people to betray their own country
should we
we shouldn't but unfortunately and this
gets to the point which you and i both
alluded to a moment ago this is about
something much bigger than eileen goo
look she's supported by she's sponsored
by victoria's secret louis vuitton the
chinese companies like ultra which uses
chinese forced labor to bring in cotton
to make the shoes and athletic apparel
that these athletes make money off of
and these corporate ceos somewhat tied
to the point you were making a little
bit earlier about the the inherent
weakness in american corporations and i
would add to that the inherent
immorality of capitalism devoid from a
moral principled grounding is what we're
looking at here because there's not an
american company honestly tucker there's
very few american companies that
wouldn't and haven't already done the
same thing as eileen goo they've already
turned their back on the united states
of america in exchange for chinese
riches and that's why she's a symbol you
want to look at something to be really
upset about it's not the ungrateful
child of america it's the corrupt and
weak corporations of america no it's
totally right i honestly think the
shareholder system the the public
company model that we have
can't continue it it doesn't actually
work i mean these companies aren't going
to thrive if they can't think long term
and think clearly and they and they
can't what do i know seems that way will
kane i appreciate your analysis thank
you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else